it's my pleasure to welcome to the
program today joseph westfall who's a
senior fellow
at the wharton leadership program at the
university of pennsylvania also former
u.s ambassador to saudi arabia
i really appreciate your time today yeah
david glad to be with you and by the way
i'm a professor at the lottery institute
at wharton
okay uh an important uh important detail
um we get credit for that so uh when it
comes to you know we've talked for a
long time about the the u.s relationship
with saudi arabia
and i think that there's sometimes a
simple uh understanding which is
there's there's a goal for shared
stability in the region
often in connection with with oil prices
and the oil industry
is it quite that simple or or how would
you explain
the history of the relationship no i
think it's
it's a lot more complicated than that
and uh
you know the the one thing you have to
remember about
saudi arabia is that u.s public opinion
that is the average
american in gallup polls at the gallup
polls from the 1930s to today to the
latest polls
see saudi arabia in
unfavorable terms a majority of
americans think of saudi arabia in
unfavorable ways
yes and that reflects back to the
attitude that members of congress then
have to have because they get pressure
from constituents
some of that is because there's no
knowledge saudi arabia was closed
until recently to the world so americans
haven't traveled there they haven't seen
the country they haven't visited
although many saudis have come to the
united states
to study and to work here so i think
that's
that lack of knowledge and that
unfavorable rating play a big role the
other thing is of course that it is the
birthplace of islam
so you know you cannot ignore a country
that
you know hosts millions of people every
year
uh for religious services and and it has
the kind of
influence that they have around the
world and have had for for a long time
um in addition to the fact that the
region
were not just for oil but for
trade and for also for
uh big nation powerful nations china
russia
and others has become a a very important
region where
we're all competing over the last
i don't know how many years i mean we
can we can talk about the last five
years but it's really
sort of been been seated earlier than
that
there has been much made publicly of
what seems to be a kind of
liberalization
in some sense in saudi arabia arguably
at least to some degree because of the
uh
direction that mohammed bin salman wants
to see the country go but at the same
time
uh while publicly you know we're hearing
about women can now drive and some of
these other things
we know about uh you know the
sequestering
of dozens of of officials in a hotel in
order to
interrogate and sometimes sometimes make
threats and even much much worse
so as from a diplomatic perspective
uh when one thing is happening publicly
and yet very different things are
happening privately
what are the conversations like between
american diplomats and the leaders of
the country do they
do they talk about what's happening
behind the scenes as much as they talk
about what's happening publicly
well it depends on which diplomats
you're talking about
okay and that's really really good
question because diplomacy really
changed dramatically after the obama
administration
so when when i left in 2017
at the in january at the end of the
obama administration
um none of the things you pointed out
had happened um muhammad binayaf was
still the crown prince
i had excellent meetings with him the
king
and muhammad bin salman upon leaving
we had had a great relationship we
worked on everything from
their economic transformation plan which
mbs had put forth
we worked on security issues with
mohammed bin nayef
we had a great relationship extensive
relationship trying to deal with all the
regional issues in syria iraq and of
course yemen
we were fully fully engaged as an
embassy
in almost every aspect of the
relationship or every aspect of
of their economy education
energy you name it transportation etc
we were involved when i left in 2017
president trump did not appoint an
ambassador for two years
right and so the only diplomacy that was
going on
was between pompeo
secretary pompeo who would occasionally
travel there and
uh kushner
so so there wasn't the embassy was not
empowered to work
any of these issues and didn't have
access
and of course after i left about a month
or two after i left
mbs was able to get his father to
compose mbn muhammad bin nayef
right as crown prince and he was named
the crown prince
and then all the things that you
mentioned started to happen
when so i think to answer your question
briefly and let me give you a chance to
add some more diplomacy is critical but
you've got to be engaged
holistically now when you were there
certainly you were aware and there was
this history of the public executions
and so on and so forth does that
get swept under the rug during
diplomatic conversations about for
example yemen or is that present in the
room
it's it's it did not get swept under by
us
from the president from president obama
to the secretary of state kerry to
myself
and i'll just choose myself as an
example uh
some ambassadors in some countries
germany switzerland
sweden others would publicly
criticize and publicly
you know be very negative about some of
these practices early on when i first
got there
uh i chose a different method i chose
the the idea that we needed to
to help them make the right decisions
but not going public with them in order
to have access and confidence that
from them in us that we weren't going to
you know
so i had the conversations with the king
with the crown prince with the deputy
crown prince about
lashings about beheadings
about security executions public
executions
about the role of the matawa uh the
religious police
who were increasingly becoming a real
real problem for them as and especially
for everybody else
and i was afraid that they were going to
start um
perhaps at some point have attacking our
foreign diplomats
so i was very straight with them that we
weren't going to tolerate any of this
stuff it had to change and it had to
change
because our relationship was so
important
now how do they react i mean do they do
they write it off as well you know that
we just do things differently here than
you do in the united states
or do they are they aware of how those
practices are seen around the world
yes yes absolutely they especially
uh mb mb uh mbs uh
is was then very keen on knowing
uh what foreign press was saying about
saudi arabia
about him about their practices so they
were very well aware of that
and very well aware that that our
ability to
support his plans for the economy
for transformation for modernizing the
country
depended on eliminating those those
ancient practices that that he didn't
agree with
right and we're tolerated because
it was still a very conservative element
within saudi arabia's people
who you know i don't know if they
demanded that but they expected that
so when i went to talk to them about it
um
they got it and they took action and
they eliminated all those things
the tower went back to the to the uh to
their precincts
uh the the lashings
were terminated and the president was
saying the same thing
in meetings with the king whenever you
come he he did four trips to saudi
arabia
i was present at three of them one was
before i became ambassador
now from much of what i've read uh it's
unclear
well i'll put it a different way from
what i've read
it's not clear to me whether the reasons
that mohammed bin salman
uh uh is taking these positions of
you know the the reforms that you talked
about and that i talked about if it's
because this is really what he believes
or rather it's because they seem to
recognize
that uh the oil industry may not be
the best place to be solely focused in
the future
there's this idea of diversifying the
saudi sovereign wealth fund they need to
be playing nice
with london and new york and so on and
so forth and that it's really
you know just just more of a strategic
and financial decision like what makes
you think that
mohammed bin salman really thinks these
aren't good practices
well you know when he would again when i
was ambassador
um he took some trips to the united
states
yeah in those trips he met with
everybody he went to california he met
with
you know the the tech people he met with
facebook people he made with bloomberg
uh he he met with dozens of people uh
across the board i got him uh i wanted
them to do
their their big um when their big
investment
in through the um their ip
ipo through the new york stock exchange
right at the new york stock exchange
and and you know it was clear that he
was trying to build
support for his economic transformation
plan
and he wanted the united states involved
he wanted the united states engaged
president obama actually met with him
and had him over at the white house for
a meeting
uh so things were i thought things were
going very well
and you thought it was a genuine desire
to reform not just a financial incentive
you know i'm convinced it was you know
the way the way i started with him was
when i first got there
uh the king salman was the crown prince
right who was also a great guy and i
really enjoyed
working with him but muhammad uh excuse
me king salman was the crown prince and
he's the one that i principally worked
with because he was the
sort of the prime minister and
i noticed his son sitting in a couple of
meetings
far off in the corner not participating
and so i asked for a meeting with him
and we met and from that first meeting
where we just got to know each other
um i realized two things one
this this young man is someday going to
be the king of saudi arabia
number one number two he because he's
ambitious and
and he has always been interested
in the polit economic development of his
country from the time he was a young man
how do i know that because i did some
background work on him
so i saw it his his other brothers
were not necessarily of the same vein
but he was and that's why his father
loved him so much because his father was
a consummate politician and his son
was like him and so we developed a great
friendship
and the friendship was you know tell
each other the truth i will tell you
exactly what i think
i represent the president and my country
and i will tell you exactly what i think
and i expect you not to be polite back
if you don't agree with me if you're not
gonna do what
i ask you to do then just tell me and
then we'll negotiate further
and that's the way we worked for for the
three years i was there
in the sort of limited time we have left
the jamal khashoggi
murder i'm curious your thoughts
uh on how the trump administration
responded to that initially donald trump
kind of saying
i don't know i just spoke to the king
and it they say they weren't involved
that
i believe them i don't know seems seems
pretty reasonable and then of course
the more we learned about it the more we
learned about how
at the very close to the very top if not
at the very top
they seem to have known exactly what was
going on how do you think that was
handled by the trump administration
i don't think it was handled well at all
and i think that that in some ways
they should have done to some extent
what president biden is doing now
saying you know we're not gonna we're
not gonna cut we don't we can't prove
without a without a without any doubt
that he ordered this um he has publicly
said he didn't that there's a
rogue operation but whatever we know
uh whatever we understand from it uh
we're going to have to recalibrate as
the president
biden has put it this relationship
um and he didn't do that you know
i mean again there was no
real diplomacy going on uh there was no
effort to really end this war in yemen
in an aggressive way
there was no effort to uh to tone down
the ambitions
uh of the crown prince and his ambitions
are are some of them are personal for
his own power and
influence right but many of them are
also for his country
and we needed to be sure that that you
know we can offset the influence that
other countries like china
um would begin to have um
instead trump was focusing only on the
sale of military
hardware yes and and i i thought that
was
absolutely wrong uh we've been speaking
with former u.s ambassador to saudi
arabia arabia joseph westfall
uh i so appreciate your time today and
this will certainly be an issue we will
continue discussing
wonderful to be with you david thank you
very much